foreign
so hi everybody good morning good
afternoon good evening depending on
where you are in the world right now my
name is Keegan cook I'm part of the
center for entrepreneurial studies here
at the GSB and
um first of all I want to say
congratulations uh on being admitted to
the GSB uh I'm sure I'm not the only one
to say that this is the remarkable
achievement and you're all incredible
people and I really look forward to
getting to know you uh once you're on
campus
I'm gonna spend a little time today
going over some information about the
entrepreneurial resources here at
Stanford but I'm hoping that this will
be more casual and that we will have
plenty of time for Q a uh to answer any
questions you have
if you have any pressing questions while
I'm talking feel free to interrupt me or
put questions in the chat and my
colleagues Nancy and summer can help me
help interrupt me as well if uh if I'm
starting to ramble and I'm not answering
the questions
all right
so
if there's one message I want you to
walk away
with from this meeting is that
entrepreneurship is in the water here at
Stanford uh and especially here at the
GSB and so uh you probably have already
gotten the sense before but I'll just
I'll just share some information to kind
of uh shed some light on that so about
25 to 30 percent of the alums of the GSB
have started one company uh at least one
company
um about 40 of those have founded
multiple companies and are serial
entrepreneurs and about 30 percent uh
get fundraising from the VC uh uh
industry here and as you can imagine a
lot of the alums from the GSB end up as
VCS too
uh entrepreneurship is is uh very much
uh recognized and welcomed by our
faculty uh and our uh research
researchers here at Stanford this this
is a cultural norm here and that may be
a differentiating point between the GSB
and other schools
and of course the location we are in we
are in the heart of Silicon Valley and
uh investors come to campus all the time
entrepreneurs go into the Silicon Valley
and meet with investors all the time and
so just being in this ecosystem it's
it's in the water
this is Mickey uh she is the founder of
a company called a day uh she's uh
showing off her new line of uh
comfortable Workwear for women
um and she's up to the races she's
running this company now and the message
here is that
alums out of the GSB found companies big
and small
some of the more well-known names you
may have heard of recently are doordash
some of you may have gotten some food
from doordash Recently
um you may have seen them on Shark Tank
in the last couple weeks as well uh uh
the the Align Technologies the creators
of Invisalign
Marketo a marketing software uh and uh
Sofi for example and these these really
run the gamut of industry and focus on
impact and software versus Hardware
so about 15 to 19 of students graduating
from the GSB are actively working on
Ventures as they graduate and this is a
differentiating point from a lot of
other schools this is quite High
and you will find uh write-ups and
quotes and quants and other news outlets
about the high levels of VC funded
companies coming out of the GSB
and when you come to Stanford you will
notice that the interest level in your
fellow cohort is very high so 65 to 75
percent of the incoming class uh
expresses a high interest in learning
about entrepreneurship
here you can see uh Robin showing off
her smitten ice cream to her fellow
classmates and and faculty members
and um
a lot of these students come to the GSB
already uh having some entrepreneurial
experience themselves either working in
a startup or or founding and they bring
those really interesting experiences
into the classroom
when you're at the GSB for the last
couple of years a hundred percent of the
class has taken at least one
entrepreneurial class while they're here
and the average is uh students take
about seven to eight uh entrepreneurial
classes
well the interest is very high
and when we talk about entrepreneurship
we don't want you to just think about a
form of Entrepreneurship where you found
the company there's other forms of
Entrepreneurship that we are very
welcoming and supportive of here at the
GSB so the first example is the founder
route where you're bounding a company
from scratch maybe becoming the CEO uh
like Elise Smith here who founded Praxis
Labs it's a she uses VR technology to
train large corporations on diversity
and inclusion
but there's other forms of
Entrepreneurship where you're starting
as a very early stage employee maybe the
CEO or or head of product like Selena
here
there's another model of
Entrepreneurship that we call switch
funds this is a really interesting model
where you uh get financial support for
some period of time for you to go find
an existing company to acquire and
become the CEO of
and Stanford is is recognized as kind of
a pioneer of this model and has become a
very uh popular with very interesting
rates of return
if you're interested in forming a social
Enterprise or or an impact focused
Enterprise whether it be non-profit or
for-profit we have special programming
and people dedicated to support those
types of Endeavors whether it be for
social impact or environmental impact
and we have formed a tight collaboration
between the GSB and the new school of
sustainability to specifically support
entrepreneurs who want to work in the
sustainability space
and then there's also you know being
intrapreneurial and uh encouraging and
fostering Innovation within large
corporations and the pedagogy and the
curriculum you'll be exposed to here uh
helps you with that career path as well
so to create this ecosystem there's a
lot of resources available to you
there's over 50 elective courses on
entrepreneurship and Innovation that you
can take advantage of
uh there's so many courses that we have
to group them into buckets so there's uh
courses around startup fundamentals to
kind of get you exposed to the the
decision-making processes of an
entrepreneur there's classes called
experiential entrepreneurship classes
and I'll I'll touch on that in the next
slide but these are classes where you're
actually learning by doing so you're
actually evaluating real Venture ideas
uh during your time in a class
and learning entrepreneurship that way
there's classes on scaling
on specific functions of
Entrepreneurship and specific Industries
and of course social and environmental
entrepreneurship courses as well
and so with all these courses you can
really design your own unique Pathway to
make sure you get the learning outcomes
that you want
I'll touch on these experiential courses
so the GSB has four itself
um but GSB students have access to
experiential courses outside of the GSB
and across the campus and in total
there's about 12. and they they all um
are rigorous they're all highly rated
they're all very intense
um but students really gain a lot of
great experience in these courses as
they go through the Innovation process
by evaluating their own Venture ideas
and some of you may have heard of a Lean
Startup methodologies or design thinking
methodologies those are pervasive
throughout all of these classes and so
you'll see similar themes between these
classes but each of them has their own
unique lens so there's classes on on
climate Tech in particular there's
classic classes on biomedical devices in
particular there's classes on creating
social Enterprises in particular so lots
of options
I'll just mention that a model that the
GSB really loves is in all of these
classes uh we the GSB really encourages
a teaching team that involves a tenure
line faculty member who does research
along with the practitioner so a Serial
entrepreneur or an investor out in the
real world this is a picture of our
startup garage class where Stefanos is
our faculty uh who does research and
operations and Entrepreneurship and
behind him is a teaching team full of
Serial entrepreneurs and investors and
it's through that combination that you
get it's really powerful and nuanced
curriculum where you know the faculty
member will say here's the trends that
we're seeing in research and in my
surveys and then the practitioners will
say this is how it manifests in the real
world and how I'm interacting with
entrepreneurs on a day-to-day basis
outside of the classroom setting we have
a lot of co-curricular uh programming
one I'll mention now is the Stanford
Venture studio so this is not a class
but it's a a supplement to class the
classes where in a class setting you
have to follow a week by week curriculum
and to be exposed to certain things week
by week inventor Studio
there's no set programming that you have
to take advantage take take part in you
tell us where you are in your process
and we have resources that you can tap
into to support you at that moment so
this could this could be uh hey I'm
thinking about incorporating
um what's the difference between this
option and this option and we'll we'll
connect you with some legal guidance uh
it could be hey I'm developing this
prototype and I'm getting some really
weird feedback that I don't know how to
interpret we can we can set you up with
a particular expert on that there's
deals and discounts to different things
and expert office hours come in all the
time and we do workshops and ask me
anything sessions with serial
entrepreneurs and so this is more of a
resource Hub that you can take advantage
of throughout your entire process
in addition to a community so these
These are kind of the overview of the
benefits of the Venture studio and one
of the biggest benefits is this
community of over
2500 people uh both current students and
alums who you can tap into for very
particular things so I've I've seen
posts to the community of hey do you uh
does anybody have a connection to this
uh buyer within Best Buy and someone
will respond saying oh yeah I can do a
warm intro for you or hey I need to talk
to a lawyer in the uh Sports IP space
and the community will will be there to
support you and make connections
uh here's a fun picture of folks working
in the Venture Studio that a lot of
students focus on software Innovations
um as you can imagine all the pictures
I'm showing you I think are Hardware
Innovations because uh those make much
prettier pictures software Innovations
don't really make good pictures uh but
uh so this team kinemo is working on a
virtual Fitness platform this team was
making a magnetic bike pedal
uh team formation so one of the biggest
assets that you would gain here at the
GSP is the connection to your fellow
classmates
um because you're all very impressive
people and building up your network and
finding potential co-founders for your
current venture or future Venture is one
of the best things you can do here at
Stanford and we have a lot of resources
available to help you form those teams
those different websites and different
mixers that we run
uh so this this is just a picture of one
of the platforms we use called the team
formation code
okay so I'm going to talk a little bit
about summer opportunities
so these are opportunities for you to
take advantage of between your first
year and your second year uh in the MBA
program
and there's lots of options
uh so we have three programs that we
call Summer entrepreneurial Merchants
where you are provided with a stipend uh
and workshops and coaching for you to
evaluate your own Venture idea over the
summer
and so it's a pretty sweet deal uh for
you to get paid to work on your own
Venture we don't take any Equity there's
no strings attached uh we just want to
support your Learning Journey uh over
the summer and and there's financial
support for you to do that
if you want to establish if you want to
attest your fit in uh working in an
early stage startup there's a program
called the entrepreneurial summer
internship program where
if you find a company a early stage
startup that you want to work in but
they can't afford to pay you a healthy
salary Stanford will help supplement
your salary for the summer
so that you can have that opportunity to
work in that early stage startup
if you want to test your bit with a a
little bit later stage growth stage
company there's always a plethora of
traditional internship opportunities
available there's a particular
internship opportunities available
through our seed office who work with
growing startups in Emerging Markets
and so that's a really interesting
opportunity opportunity
we have a special programming dedicated
for allowing students to establish their
fit with a social impact Innovative firm
either small or large
and that's run by the CSI
and then I wanted to mention that we
also have a program where upon
graduation if you are launching an
impact focused Venture whether it be
social impact or environmental impact
there's a special Fellowship opportunity
available for that too to give you a
little bit more Runway that you might
need to
establish your business and get more
fundraising later on
okay so the CES team is uh comprised of
15 very talented and very interesting
and helpful people uh these pictured
here are just four uh who do a lot of
student engagements but we have a robust
team uh depending on your interests and
so we are here to support you and we
love chatting with students
um so when you're here reach out to us
get to know us
I think the best the best quote I've
heard from students is the CES team is
surprisingly helpful
people are up after they chat with us
they're they're surprised how helpful we
are
I don't know if that's a compliment or a
dig I'm not sure
there's lots of clubs
um uh still the entrepreneurship Club is
a big one social Innovation Club VC Club
Cardinal Ventures is is more of an
accelerator program uh campus-wide
the GSB and the center for
entrepreneurial studies is just one of
many organizations on campus supporting
entrepreneurs and so you at this this
website send stanford.edu lists all the
different organizations across the
campus
uh that focus on entrepreneurship and if
you have a particular industry area or
particular interest there's usually a
group dedicated to
supporting uh you and your interests so
if you're uh interested in education and
Entrepreneurship there's an education
accelerator uh if you're interested in
biomedical devices or Healthcare there's
particular entrepreneurial centers just
for that and so the GSB uh collaborates
with these centers very frequently
something you can take advantage of now
before you're even here is uh the
engineering school puts on a a webinar
series called the entrepreneurial
thought leaders program and they bring
in really top-notch Founders and
investors to talk about uh different
issues whether their own experience or
things they're seeing in the field and
um and these talks are very impressive
they're they're usually very real about
the
the highs and the lows of
Entrepreneurship
and I'll I'll end with that
um I wanted to leave enough time for
questions so we'll we'll open it up
what's what can I be helpful
when
go ahead Andrew
hello thank you for putting on this um
amazing informative event so my question
is I'm an incoming student and I have
been working for about three years and
the tech industry and I want to do
something social impact related before
enrolling in school I understand that
there's amazing programs like gmix and
even these entrepreneurial fellowships
that you highlighted for the between
year one and two I'm just curious have
any past students also felt like oh
they've been working for a few years and
they want to try doing something
entrepreneurial or social
entrepreneurial in the summer before and
then gain that perspective and focus the
curriculum accordingly
that's a great question I I'll I'll just
chime in to say it is very common for
students to test entrepreneurship in a
new way while they're here uh so that's
very very that's very much normal in
terms of the summer before coming here
I'm not sure about the resources
available uh you can before you get your
student ID you wouldn't be able to
access a lot of the preset programming
that we have
um
but uh if you're interested in social
impact in particular I would encourage
you to reach out to the folks at CSI and
they might have some interesting ideas
on what you might be able to do during
the summer before getting here
they might have exposure to certain
external internship opportunities that
we don't run but they may be aware of
okay got it thank you
all right the Salome is it please tell
me thank you thank you thank you for
telling me all good oh good thank you so
much
um first thank you for organizing this
event I was having the question realized
I would much better ask it um this way
so this
um presentation was great and there's so
many resources and opportunities the one
question I have is like how do you pick
because you can't do all at once and you
can't do all the classes at once so now
you've seen students tackle and choose
the resources and pick the right ones to
crash their Journey at Stanford and
Beyond
it's such a great question
we every year we ask students you know
what are the biggest challenges you've
had here as an entrepreneurial student
at the GSP the number two pain point
that the geospiers have is there are so
many resources uh and that it takes time
to navigate them
the best advice I can give you is talk
to CES talk to
um your MBA program team and what we'll
do is we'll focus on your learning goals
and we'll help you choose the different
classes to meet your learning goals
there there are lots of different ways
to meet your learning goals and so other
factors come into play like this is how
many credits I'm taking this quarter and
you know other factors in this
decision-making process
but um the best type of advice I can
give is just chat with us chat with CES
and chat with your MBA advisor
and we'll we'll help you
okay I see a question in the chat uh
Mark says thanks for the event I've
heard something called StarTex and
StarTex Med any chance you could
elaborate a little bit more about this
program I'm especially wondering about
its relationship to GSB and Stanford a
great question uh so I'm so stardex is
its own separate non-profit organization
uh but
historically it's been very much tied to
Stanford in a couple different ways one
is they used to only accept Stanford
Affiliates into their program
um I think they've they've become a
little bit more flexible so they do they
do have some Fringe cases uh if you're a
really exceptional founder
um but historically it's always been a
stanford-based accelerator there used to
be a fund called the Stanford StarTex
fund where Stanford University used to
fund some of the
um companies coming out of startups but
StarTex is its own non-profit its own
entity
it's a fantastic program uh they don't
take any Equity they they give you tons
of resources I went through the program
in 2014 and it was life-changing for me
um the acceptance rate is very low and
so typically you have to apply many
times to get in I think the the average
application it's like to you have to
apply 2.5 times before you're admitted
but every time you applied you get
really good feedback and so I encourage
you to keep in touch with them and apply
and if you don't get in the first time
you'll get some great feedback apply
again apply a third time
and an event you'll get in
uh Mark let me know if you have any
follow-up questions on that right uh
StarTex Med they have a particular arm
to support medical uh devices and health
Tech Innovations
um but it's a fantastic program I would
say one of their strengths is
fundraising
so if you're in the uh path they have
different programming but one of their
strengths is fundraising so if you're if
you're like let's say you've validated
some hypotheses around your solution and
your business model and you're starting
to fundraise StarTex is got a whole
bunch of programs dedicated to that
oh okay great
okay great thanks Nancy for that about
gmix
great all right Michael looks like you
have a question
hey Keegan thanks for putting the event
on uh I'd love to hear about how a
current GSB alumni who is working on a
startup that kind of uh started at well
during their time at GSB what the
different touch points were with
specific classes or resources and how it
kind of propelled them on their Journey
yeah I'm gonna thanks for your question
I'm gonna give you a composite character
uh so
let's see who should I make up
um
I'll give you an example of uh it's a
real example of
um a student who was focused on a
climate Hardware Innovation and so
there's a very specific example but I
want to give the impression that no
matter what industry you're in or what
you're doing there's specific Pathways
that you can take
so in this case uh it was a guy named
Ted
um and Ted came to Stanford with a with
a particular interest in energy and
climate didn't know what he was going to
do or work on but he took advantage of
something called explore energy it's a
week-long
session of workshops and mixers just
focused on energy he got really pumped
uh Bill started building his network uh
he came across through different classes
um an interesting uh problem space and
an interesting Innovation and hydrogen
storage and so he started deep diving
into that and he took advantage of
specific classes like there's an
experiential course called Stanford
climate Ventures
um and there's other classes uh as well
where he was able to evaluate the
viability of his business model uh in
the class and learn learn along the way
uh I think he also took advantage of
this co-curricular activity called
Venture studio
um he probably took advantage of one of
the summer immersion programs uh if not
then this composite character of Ted
should have uh so that would give him
the whole summer of evaluating
and then
um
and then upon graduation
he applied for this Stanford impact
founder program and was awarded a
hundred and ten thousand dollars to keep
on working on his Venture that gave him
a little bit more Runway to de-risk his
Tech his Tech is this uh hydrogen
storage tank that is put on the uh on
semi trucks
and so the 110 000 gave him a little bit
more Runway to de-risk the tech and uh
start uh giving a little bit more
funding and so he applied to this uh
program called the Breakthrough energy
Ventures this is a its own investment
firm uh I think co-sponsored by Bill
Gates and he won the Breakthrough energy
Ventures uh uh prize which is about four
million dollars and so now he's Off to
the Races with his company called Vern
um and
uh he we we are wishing him the best and
it looks like he's going to do great
things
so that that's an example of a very
specific use case where he he came in
didn't know what he was working on but
he was interested in the climate space
and then exited with a company and a
kind of launching pad so depending on
what you're interested in your path
might look a little different but there
is a pathway for you
very helpful thank you sure
uh okay I've got a question here from
Joseph uh I have heard great things
about the biodizing program in
connection with the medical school how
have students leverage these classes to
launch viable startups well am I and is
it more of an educational only
experience great question I don't know
about the
I don't know about the rates of how many
of the bio-design teams actually
launched their Ventures
typically for these experiential courses
biodesign is one of them typically it's
about 30 percent to 50 of the teams who
go through these courses actually end up
uh launching a venture
and that doesn't mean they launched the
Venture that they were specifying in the
class
pivoting is all part of the process and
it is very likely that they pivoted
several times after the class but these
classes uh they train you around these
Innovation processes so that you're
comfortable and pivoting and that you're
pivoting for the right reasons
um so to answer your question biodesign
is also one of these really highly rated
experiential courses uh they have a
unique model where they actually seed
particular technology Innovations or
particular problems for you to work on
in the beginning
so they'll say hey team a
um uh We've connected you based on your
interests with this very particular
problem of uh patient
compliance with medications
and uh your task for the quarter is to
investigate this problem
if you find out in like week two that
there's no interesting there there then
they allow you to Pivot to someone else
but they at least give you a starting
point
and they have external partners that
help you so you get access to patients
and access to different Technologies
um let me know if that uh answered your
question Joseph so this this educational
only component it's we definitely focus
on education so that you can use the
processes and use the learning not only
on this curve Venture but future
Ventures and whatever your career holds
but it is a very common outcome that
students actually launch after the class
all right uh looks like I got a question
from Muhammad
um thanks for putting on the event
really helpful I'm quite interested in
pursuing the public management and
social Innovation certificate could you
share any information on that
uh like how many students take it up uh
how much would the impact uh that impact
the ability to take a broader array of
courses great question
I'm not going to be the best person to
answer that the the CSI would give you a
very specific nuanced answer I'll just
say that uh what we've done is different
classes will
um
uh
apply for in the in the in the pursuit
of these certificates you have to get
certain uh credits in certain areas and
so what we've done let's say in our
startup garage class is that by taking
startup garage and doing some uh
slightly different activities during
your class
you will be able to apply that class
as a credit towards the certificate and
so I'll give a very brief example where
in the class of fall quarter of startup
garage there's a decision point where
either you fill out a certain type of
business model canvas or an impact
focused business model canvas and so if
you want the course of startup garage to
apply to the certificate you would
choose to fill out the impact version of
the business model canvas and I believe
that's the way they've done it with
other classes as well so that you can
still have a lot of flexibility
in what you're doing and still get the
credit that you need for the certificate
so I that was kind of a a half response
to get the full answer you'll want to
ask CSI but my my impression is that you
still get a lot of flexibility in my
courses you take
um okay great
oh thanks Nancy okay Nancy knows the
story
okay great
perfect
okay great any other questions
all right go ahead Solomon I have
another one
um so the question I have is uh we were
at this Regional event for
um admitted students and we talked about
different entrepreneurship courses and
uh startup brush definitely popped up
and a few more and
um what Alonso shared is that there are
going to be like applications they're
application based which means that
you'll have to fill out the application
and I've heard people also recommend
that we spent some time before starting
MBA actually crafting this idea because
when we get to start the school it's not
going to be the right there won't be any
time to actually flesh it out so the
question I have do you have any advice
on how to approach the application
closer to the date when it actually
comes out but also in preparation for
this course is there anything in
specific that we should aim for when
we're kind of trying to pitch this idea
that we have for a company that we have
to the team at startup brush it's a
great question
um so just for everybody's sake
um so startup garage is a two-quarter
course starts in the fall goes to the
winter you don't have to take both
quarters it's optional
um you can't take sort of brush fall in
your first year
you can take startup garage winter your
first year but those are typically it's
pretty rare to do that
um typically those are students who have
already started working on a venture uh
and they go into the winter already
having done some prototyping and some
business de-risking and then they'll
join the winter
so to answer your question Salome it
depends on your
interests uh
one way to think about it is that if if
the average number of pivots per team
before launching if the average is
something like 2.5 per quarter
um then there may be some work that you
can do
either before Stanford or through the
Venture Studio program or other courses
during the fall quarter
for you to already start investigating
an idea and maybe maybe you knock out
some pivots
um and then uh and then you would be in
a position to apply to the Winter
quarter of startup Garage in your first
year
um we don't we don't want any students
to feel to put too much pressure on
themselves uh because it's a much more
common path for you to First in your
first year
and get a lay of the land of
entrepreneurial activity around campus
get some entrepreneurial perspectives by
taking one of these more fundamental
courses
um and then taking starter Garage in
your second year both fall and winter
um some students will start their
entrepreneurial Journey
in the summer between their mb1 and MBA
2 by taking one of these immersion
programs
so I don't know if that answered your
question uh but there's lots of options
if if you want to for students who
really want to start evaluating Venture
ideas in the fall the best way to do
that is to take advantage of the Venture
Studio programming and the guidance from
the CES team and and the experts that we
bring in
thank you thank you really helpful okay
sure
hey Keegan and everyone this is Nancy
just jumping in to add to what you were
uh talking about Keegan
um and yes if you're trying to like
maybe put together content language that
you can be thinking about this summer
ahead of time so when that application
opens
you know you can be more of a plug and
play
um I would encourage you to
you might be able to actually reach out
to Glenn craymond he teaches an
incredible course called when winning
writing and he might have some tips for
you on how do you start crafting your
message and telling your story
um before you could get here and
actually take his course I did throw in
a quick uh link to one of his podcast
episodes what we have here about think
fast think smart
um but yeah that I think he would
actually be a good person to
help you think about yeah uh crafting
and telling your story
um perhaps before you actually
matriculate
and and thanks very much Nancy
cream Glenn grayman is well respected uh
at the GSP he's even become a verb so if
you're writing as a certain style and he
wants you to do in a different style he
you will creminize it
um so uh yeah I really recommend looking
into his classes and Salome just to tag
on your question earlier for the
application process for a startup Garage
in particular there's you'll we have a
workbook that asks for very specific
things and the best way to put your
information into that workbook is just
to consult with CES team along the way
we use a language that is very much
embedded in design thinking and mean
startup
all right any other questions
go ahead is it Yasin yes hi Mr thank you
very much for hosting this session
uh one of the hypothesis that I would
like to test during my MBA journey is
better to find out better venture
capital is the right path for me uh what
is the best way or like a good way to
test this hypothesis yeah
there's a part there's lots of different
courses and and you'll
through the e-club you'll get exposure
to different VCS CES brings nvcs all the
time and and you can build your network
that way but there are specific classes
on the perspective of investors
um Nancy and summer let me know if you
know the name of the class I'm thinking
of it's It's taught by Ilia and
um
Ellie Leo's last name starts with an S
but I can't remember what it was but
yeah
um let me go back let me look at the
title of his class
but so Ilya stribla he
alongside a VC practitioner and and they
co-teach this class and they give the
perspective of what it's like to be an
investor both an angel and a VC uh and
so what you do in that class is you you
practice being an investor so you take
in a bunch of pitches or or you know
one-page summaries you as a class decide
on what investment you're going to make
then you
um The Faculty will consult on like this
is the averaging like this is what most
people choose this is what the outcome
was was actually and and you get to
practice what it's like to be an
investor that way
what ilya's research is really
interesting because what he looks at is
he's survey he's got connections with
all these investors around the world and
what he does is he studies their
practices and their decision-making
processes and also their outcomes and so
he'll be able to apply that type of
research lens to say oh
um for this type of scenario if you were
to use this type of decision-making
process or this type of investment
thesis you would go with this conclusion
versus if you were to use this other
decision-making process you'd go with
this conclusion so it really is a unique
lens into what it's like to be an
investor
and then
um a lot of students will will become an
associate or an intern at an investment
firm over the summer to kind of get that
that real world uh exposure as well
did that answer your question Nelson
yes thank you very much sure
what else
go ahead Andrew
so
um I'm really happy Nancy put this horse
in the chat from the because I I was
just even thinking recently about
how communication is such a critical
part of just any idea right and that's a
great one for written communication I
was curious do you feel like the center
for entrepreneurial studies offers
any coursework on verbal communication
or storytelling like that type of thing
or is that more housed in GSB coursework
or is that part of the leadership
curriculum like lead Labs you know great
question and and summer and Nancy chime
in if I'm forgetting anything I'll just
cite two examples so as a GSB student
you get access to communication coaches
um and those coaches go beyond just a
like an adventure pitching format
um so they can go into you know a job
interview format or presentation format
or whatever type of communication
coaching you'd like
um there's you have access to that
in terms of and there's also classes on
on communication so uh there's a another
professor named Matt Abrams and so he
gives workshops and and had classes on
how to handle q a during an investor
pitch setting uh and so he he does
communication not only more broadly but
but for entrepreneurs in particular
and then the last thing I'll mention is
if you're part of the Venture Studio
Community we do have a pitch coach uh
come in once in a while and you get to
sign up for oh thanks Nancy you get to
sign up for one-on-one coaching with her
where you will actually have your slide
deck your pitch and you'll pitch and
then she will not only comment on your
communication style and the verbal
communication but also the content that
that you're trying to display in your
slides
but that's good to know yeah because one
of the in talking to like my specific
management at Microsoft they said that
what you exude how you exude as a leader
helps build confidence of your team that
you're leading and so there's even the
non-verbal cues and I I love the comment
about written communication but what I
was even thinking is those aspects of
non-verbal communication that are not
even you actually talking it's just the
way you hear yourself so I just wanted
to figure out how to at least even get
an assessment on that and oh maybe yeah
absolutely Matt Abrams uh he really deep
dives into this and so
um so one of the things he he coaches
the students on is when you're giving an
investor pitch uh
uh if you're the person speaking then
your other teammates should be looking
at you as if you're the most interesting
person in the world at that moment and
and and the reason why you provide that
advice is because
um he sees all these different pitches
from different teams and it is those
non-verbal cues are very indicative
about the team Dynamic so if if the if
the other team members are doing their
own thing or you know not paying
attention to the leader who's speaking
at that moment or vice versa when the
CEO then lets the you know head of
product speak and he's not he or she is
not paying attention all of those really
matter and so Matt Matt Abrams
um will give will give coaching and
workshops on that in particular
foreign
I know I it was really cool I uh ran
into Shawano on campus about a week or
so ago and um I'm like hey what how's it
going he's like I'm actually teaching
with Matt this quarter and I'm like oh
my gosh that's amazing
I just I'll just say one more thing
about Matt Abrams one of the reasons one
of the reasons why he's so credible in
this particular capacity of helping
entrepreneurial teams pitch is because
what he uh does in addition to teaching
is he consults
um big investment firms and consults the
startups that they've already invested
in to help their startups get more money
uh and so he while he teaches students
in the early stages here he also does
Consulting uh out in the real world
where he's teaching entrepreneurs you
know the buying techniques and raising
more money
what other questions do people have
um
speaking of Matt he he does a podcast oh
think smart think fast and I just put
the link oh think fast thanks
yes anyway okay
that's talk smart I put the link in here
so this is something that you can start
engaging with
um uh to
Keegan's Point
um and Communications this is something
that anyone in the general public can
get involved in and take a look at so
stuff to do no matter where you choose
to go to Business School
no great
what else
you know
well I'm happy to stick around if
anybody wants to stick around
um but other than that
thanks so much for all your great
questions congratulations again
um let us know if CES can be helpful to
you
and if we can't be helpful to you we'll
direct you to other people who can be
helpful
and have a wonderful restful son well
what what month is this I almost wanted
to say it's summer already have a good
uh have a good spring and summer and
hope to see you in the fall
[Music]